[MUSIC PLAYING]
VAN RIPER: We're going to start
the live stream now, so
for the benefit of the
live stream, I'd like
to introduce this.
We have Josh Woodward here from
the GDG Fresno who's also
a member of the GDG[x]
project.
And the GDG[x] project, well,
he'll talk about it some more,
but let me just say
it's way cool.
We got a bunch of organizers,
not just here in the US but
from all over the world, that
have been working on several
open source projects
on GitHub.
And one in particular that
just launched on the Play
Store, the Frisbee project, is
that application that you can
use here in Silicon Valley to
see what's going with our GDG,
but also with the East Bay GDG,
the GDG in Fresno, the
GDG in San Francisco, actually
a GDG anywhere in the world.
I don't know if you realize it,
but we have GDGs in more
than a hundred countries to
date, and this app actually
locates you and tells you what
activities around the GDGs is
happening where you are.
So if you're traveling to the
East Coast, and you're kind of
bored, and you want to find a
GDG event, you can look it up.
So he's going to talk about that
tonight, and I'm get very
proud of these people that
they're volunteering their
time above and beyond their
organizer volunteer time
already to work on
these projects.
They're not being compensated
in any way for this.
It's a free app they're
giving out.
And I guess I'll just turn
it over to Josh.
So take it away, Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH WOODWARD: OK.
So like Van said, my name
is Josh Woodward.
I organized GDG Fresno, which
is like two and a half hours
away from here.
Back at Google I/O last year,
we have a GDG organizer's
summit where all the organizers
from all over the
world come and share ideas
and stuff like that.
And every year at this summit,
all the organizers say we need
a tool to do this, and we need a
tool to do that, and help us
organize our chapters,
and stuff like that.
I've been doing this for over
three years now, and I hear
the same requests for tools.
Through I/O, I met other
organizers and stuff, and we
got together and we decided to
actually do something now.
And so we came up with GDG[x].
Let me show a little
video here that one
of our members made.
It's pretty cool.
So we'll show that real quick.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOSH WOODWARD: So that's just
a little teaser video.
We like to just have fun and
stuff, so I call ourselves a
covert ops team, because
there's like over 400
organizers.
Well, 400 groups, over 1,000
organizers, and we're a group
of like 15 of them.
And so, we work in secret and
build these little projects
and stuff like that.
So I just make fun
a little bit.
So why GDG[x]?
I think it's fun.
It is a play on the
Google[x] project.
We're not building Google Glass
or self-driving cars,
but when you're doing this
stuff in your spare time,
building a website is a
pretty big project.
And then Louis Gray said that
it's not just x, it's extreme.
So I had to throw that
quote in there.
That was funny.
He put that on one
of his videos.
Some of the projects we've
done is Project Glider.
It's just the Google I/O HTML5
slides rebranded for GDG.
We have a project called
Boomerang which is a
boilerplate website template
for the GDG organizers, and
Project Frisbee which
is the Android app.
Like I said, Project Glider is
just the I/O slides rebranded.
It's not mirrored here,
so I got to look
over my shoulder here.
But it's like the Google
I/O HTML5 slides.
We just rebranded them.
So this is all HTML5,
just real easy.
Let's see.
What else?
Oops.
And then Project Boomerang is
one that I was like the lead
on and I worked on.
It's a boilerplate for the other
chapters to easily build
a website from nothing,
really.
So here's GDG Fresno's
website.
It pulls all of our information
from Google+, and
stuff like that.
It pulls news from Google+.
These are all Google posts.
They just get fed into
the website.
And all of our events from the
Google Developer's site, past
and future events.
AUDIENCE: That's a lot
of future events.
JOSH WOODWARD: We got
four planned.
Are DevFest is in there, and
I think we have a recurring
learning Android with
Android Studio.
So that one's a repeat event
that happens every month.
And then it goes photos from
Google+, so it's real easy.
All someone has to do is change
three variables, and
they have a full website.
It's always up to date because
it's just pulling content from
Google+ or the developers.com
site.
It's written in AngularJS
and Twitter Bootstrap.
Three lines of code, and
they can deploy it.
It's all front end so they
can deploy it anywhere.
You can host it on Google Drive,
you can host it on
Google App Engine, whatever.
And we also built a Yeoman
generator so it's
even easier to deploy.
You just have to answer three
questions, and you get a build
script that builds up your
website for you.
This is the reason
Van invited me to
talk, was Project Frisbee.
This has been a very
popular release.
I think we released it a week
ago, and it already is over
1,000 installs and
stuff like that.
So it's pretty cool.
It's a GDG Android app.
It is location-based, so
you can open the app--
say you travel a lot, and you're
sitting in your hotel,
and you're bored.
Maybe there's a GDG meetup
going on nearby.
You can open up the app.
It sees you, that you're
close to Boston, and
there's the GDG in Boston.
And maybe they're having
to meetup.
You can go visit that meetup.
We also added all the upcoming
DevFests to be app.
So say you want to travel
somewhere else to visit a
DevFest because the DevFests
are the larger event.
You can search through all of
the DevFests on your Android
app and find one, and book some
tickets, and fly out of,
I don't know, wherever
We also have all the Google
Developers Live videos on the
Android app sorted by category,
like Android Chrome,
Cloud, stuff like that.
And I'll show you some
screenshots here.
The app is live on
the Play Store.
If you have an Android device,
you can go to this URL,
gdg-x.com/frisbee, and it'll
redirect you to the Play Store
app, and you can download
it right now.
And here are the screenshots
for that.
This is GDP Fresno.
It may be hard to see
in the back there.
This is GDG Fresno loaded, the
info about it, so it shows the
organizers, the about, and
some links that we have.
There's all of our events,
future and past events right
on the Android app.
There's the DevFest screen, so
you can find all the DevFests
that are coming up.
There's the Google Developers
Live screen, and that's the
Android page so you can quickly
watch videos from
Google Developers Live right
on your Android.
And then there's the list
of contributors.
This is a global effort.
We have translations in--
I don't know if that's the
language, but Ukraine.
The Ukraine guy translated it.
We have Spanish, French,
Russian.
A lot of help has gone in from
the other organizers to
translate the app for us.
GDG[x]
as a whole, we have a board
now, so that we're kind of
like organized and structured.
And then we also have a lot
of people involved.
Kevin's up there, but he
doesn't do anything.
He doesn't do anything.
And that's GDG[x].
[APPLAUSE]
VAN RIPER: Any questions
for Josh?
JOSH WOODWARD: One question.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOSH WOODWARD: Oh yeah, sorry.
I think I ended it early.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
That was the GitHub picture
in the last slide.
JOSH WOODWARD: That was, huh?
Let's see here.
Real quick.
MALE SPEAKER: That last
slide might have--
JOSH WOODWARD: I think
it was all on there.
I prematurely--
I forgot about the last slide.
So, yes, you can contribute.
You can look at all
the source.
You can do everything
on our GitHub page.
You can circle us on Google+,
and we have a YouTube channel
that we upload videos to
and stuff like that.
Post the slides?
They are posted.
It's gdg-x.com/gdgsv.
MALE SPEAKER: So just
quick housekeeping--
yeah, thank you, Josh.
Quick housekeeping before--
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: --before Wes hops
up here, just to remind
everybody to turn off their cell
phones so there aren't
any interruptions.
And then the restrooms are
around the sides over there if
anyone needs that.
And you're welcome to take
pictures and things in this
room, but outside of this
room, don't do that.
Remember, you're a guest.
Don't take pictures outside
of the room.
Don't bother the people trying
to work and things like that.
VAN RIPER: And I just want to
remind people, we are live
streaming tonight, so if
it's a short question--
and Wes is open to questions
while he's presenting--
he'll need to repeat it.
If it's a longer question,
you'll probably want
to go to that mic.
And when we actually get to the
Q&A at the end, I would
really ask that you use the mic
so that anyone in the live
stream can also hear
the questions.
All right?
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Here's Wesley.
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: Wait!
I have to get the right
talk first.
I think this is the right one.
All right, welcome to DevFest.
[LAUGHTER]
WESLEY CHUN: I'm just kidding.
No, seriously though, DevFest
season is coming up.
We're really excited that we're
going to have these
events, again, globally around
the world, supported by the
GDGs such as yourselves.
This will be a talk that some
of us on the team have
designed to be delivered at GDGs
around the world, and I'm
just giving one sample delivery
of it so that people
get an idea of what the talk
is all about, the vibe and
things like that.
So that's what I'm here for.
Tonight we're going to talk
about Google App Engine and
give you an overview of other
cloud computing products,
whether they're a part of our
Cloud Suite or other products
that Google has.
I'm Wesley Chun.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Developer Relations team,
and are we all ready
to get started?
You're supposed to say, "Wait
a minute, wait a minute!
This guy has a collar on, can't
trust him." People with
collars, right, very scary.
So let's get real here.
I have to wear my
developer wear.
[LAUGHTER]
WESLEY CHUN: All right, now
you can believe me, right?
OK, cool.
So, years ago, I would say three
or four years ago, you
would have somebody on my team
come up and give you a talk on
App Engine, and introduced you
to cloud computing, and say
what App Engine is, and hope
that you get on your way.
That was the case a couple of
years ago, but since then lots
of changes have happened.
Most notably, we can't just talk
about App Engine anymore.
That's not the complete
picture.
It used to be our only cloud
product, but now we have a lot
more things.
We actually have a
real platform.
App Engine is just one
component out of many
different cloud services
that we have now.
So the Cloud platform team
asked me to say a little
something about the platform
just so that people
are aware of it.
I'm very happy to do so.
Just because I'm talking about
App Engine tonight doesn't
mean that you're limited to just
that one particular tool.
There's plenty other
ones, all right?
And hopefully as the year goes
by, you'll be hearing talks in
each individual one of these
products, because they're all
pretty exciting in
their own right.
So a little bit more about me.
I'm a software engineer.
I've been an engineer
for 25 years now.
I'm getting kine of
old, actually.
If you don't believe it, how
many of you guys know what
punch cards are?
I learned FORTRAN
on punch cards.
That's my age group.
So I'm just like you guys.
I guess a little bit
more about me.
The thing that I built that most
people know about is I
was one of the original
engineers the built Yahoo Mail
about 15 years ago using Python
when no one ever heard
of it before.
And we created a web framework
before that term even existed.
So that was pretty fun.
I worked at all kinds of other
interesting places.
Probably the strangest thing
that I've done is using Python
to work on software for doctors
to help them analyze
patients with spinal fractures,
so talk to me about
osteoporosis later.
Men get it, too.
Don't think it's just
a woman thing.
Work out, do weights,
don't smoke.
Those things are all good
for your bones.
I'm also a writer, so some of
you guys may know Python.
Anybody out there, Python?
Yes, yes, yes?
OK, then.
You may have seen or heard
one of my books.
I like to write.
Which is kind of weird, because
typically engineers
don't like to document their
code, much less write a book,
so I'm one of the mutants
out there.
Another thing that I like to do
is I've been teaching for
over 30 years now.
I think 30 years ago exactly
I got my first
paycheck as a teacher.
I've been teaching locally.
I give talks at conferences.
I'm a part time faculty at
Foothill, which is close by.
I really like teaching, and
talking to people, and getting
developers excited about
technologies.
But enough about me.
This talk is actually about you
guys, so hopefully you're
some sort of developer, or a
tech lead, or some sort of
tech manager or product manager,
entrepreneur, QA
tester, product manager,
something like that.
You're curious about or you're
new to Google Tools.
This may be your
first meeting.
Whose first meaning
is it here today?
Wow, great.
That's roughly about a third.
So welcome, everybody.
Glad that you can came, and hope
that everybody makes you
feel welcome.
Don't feel shy.
Go talk to people because,
hey, they may be doing
something that you may be
interested in hearing about.
Or you want to know more about
the Google Cloud Platform, so
I'm going to start there.
I'm going to talk a little about
the Platform first, then
go into App Engine, and then
talk about how the whole
ecosystem works, and then what
other Google tools and
services are similar that you
may want to consider for
applications that you
may want to build.
Here's the structure
of the talk.
It's really broken under
three main parts.
I'll give a little bit
background, motivation, as to
why we're in the cloud business,
why App Engine was
created, things like that.
Then most of the talk will be
focused on the App Engine
product itself, and then I'll
talk a little bit more about
each of the other cloud platform
tools that I think
you should look at, as well as
other services from Google
that are not part of the
Cloud Platform but
they're cloudy in nature.
And if there's lots of time
permitting, I can start doing
some hands-on coding as well,
but at least I'll point you to
a place that you can
get started with.
And due to the hard work of one
of my coworkers, you can
actually start playing around
with App Engine without doing
any downloads whatsoever.
You can just go straight from
a browser window to the
website and start playing
around with App Engine.
So I think that's a really
exciting change, and it's just
reduces the barrier of entry
for people who want to just
try and play with
the Platform.
So that's really the structure
of the talk tonight.
Let's talk a little
bit about scale.
I know some of you guys are
going to know the answers to
these because these numbers
were released around I/O
timeframe, so I know you guys
keep your ears and eyes open
to Google News every single day,
looking for information.
But in case you don't know some
of these numbers, I want
you to start thinking about
googley sized numbers.
Like if I was to ask you on a
random day in 2012, what do
you think the size of
our search index
is in terms of bytes?
What would be the kind of
number you would say?
Another question I want you to
think about is, well, since
we're talking about numbers, how
much video do you think is
uploaded to YouTube in terms
of hours every minute?
How many hours of video are
uploaded to YouTube every
single minute?
That would be a number
from this year, from
Google I/O, of course.
Then since we're talking about
YouTube anyway, how many
people on this planet this
year watch at least one
YouTube video a month, or at
least their IP address does?
All right.
So think about that.
And then as you're thinking
about that, and I start
talking about the App Engine
product, I'll ask you a
related question, which is how
many hits do you think App
Engine gets across all of its
apps every single day?
And by that, I mean my page
views, or just any HTTP, Get,
Post, or whatnot.
So those are some numbers that
I want you to think about.
I will go over that halfway
through the talk.
And then the other thing I want
you to think about it is
how many times have you gone to
google.com and not have it
respond or gotten an internal
server error
or some other 500?
Probably doesn't happen
all that often.
Maybe a couple of you may have
seen some of those, but really
they're very rare.
And the reason for that is we
have a staff of people who are
up around the clock to make sure
that the system is up and
it's responsive.
That is the kind of reliability
that you would
love to have for your
own apps, right?
I mean, it just takes away some
of that worry and give
you peace of mind
that you want.
Let's go back to the top.
What's a good approximate size
of our search index around
last year in terms of bytes?
Anybody?
Rough number?
100 bytes?
100 million?
A terabyte?
A petabyte?
What's the difference
between a terabyte
and a petabyte, anyway?
It's a p, a t, and the r?
Right?
Petabyte is another 10 to
the 3 higher than that.
In 2012, it was 100 petabytes,
but I like to say 100 million
gigs because that's sort of
easier to kind of understand.
Because once you start using
peta, exa, all those things,
it just becomes mumbo jumbo.
So you really want
to start thinking
about things like that.
How about YouTube?
How much video is uploaded
to YouTube every minute?
AUDIENCE: 10,000 [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHUN: 6,000?
10,000 7,000?
OK, let's just round
it off for 100.
100 hours a minute, which
is roughly about four
days worth of video.
When I gave this talk earlier,
somebody asked the question
that I couldn't answer, which
was what percentage of those
100 hours are cat videos?
[LAUGHTER]
WESLEY CHUN: I'm sorry.
We may have some machine
learning code that has figured
that out, but I haven't
been told yet.
So I'm sorry I can't answer
that question.
How many people on this planet
watch at least one YouTube
video a month?
Not that many.
Just a billion.
It's a small number.
Those are just some numbers.
I'm planting the seeds to have
you think about scale.
That's the point
of this slide.
Then another thing I want you to
think about is not only do
we have out of this world
scaling, but we also have out
of this world innovation,
and security.
You can tell that's out of this
world security, right?
That's actually a Street
View picture from
one of our data centers.
This is probably the one
in North Carolina.
This one is what our data
centers look like with a
professional photographer.
That's Iowa, I believe.
So you can find these
all online.
You can use them, actually, as
backgrounds for your computer
if you want.
They're actually very pretty.
But in reality, on an everyday
basis, they kind
of look like this.
Because I know, I've been
inside a couple of them.
They're more blase, but
actually that one
looks really good.
Anyway, just kind of keep in
mind the scale that we have.
The other thing is innovation.
Google has spent many, many
years building a lot of
technologies that have really
launched the era of big data.
You the names.
MapReduce.
You hear BigTable.
You hear all these things, but
when you realize that those
things are six years old or
seven years old, it kind of
blows your mind, right?
And now, actually we've moved
beyond these technologies.
Google File System, all
these things, we're
moving beyond them now.
We've got newer technologies.
Dremel, Spanner, Colossus.
That is what's going to take
us to the next level.
Same goes for you guys.
As we come up with these
innovations, we make them
available to you guys, and you
can use them to build your
next awesome app with.
Before we start talking about
cloud products and things like
that, let's talk a little bit
about service levels.
Because what happens is as
I roamed the hallways--
maybe not here, but in other
places, or at conferences--
I hear people talking about
cloud computing.
It's a big deal.
They may throw around SaaS, and
infrastructure, and all
these words.
And sometimes people don't
really know exactly what
they're saying except they're
just trying to make their
conversation buzzword-compliant.
That's fine if you think you
want to sound like you know
what you're talking about, but
I think there should have a
better understanding.
So the purpose of this slide is
to make sure that we're all
on the same page as to what is
a cloud service level, what
products work at those levels
so that when you do want to
talk about one product versus
another, one vendor versus
another, that you're actually
making the appropriate
connections and comparisons.
Instead of just saying things
like, oh, should I use App
Engine or should I use EC2?
People used to ask that all the
time, but that question
doesn't make sense because
that's an apples versus
oranges type of comparison,
because both products serve
very different levels.
So just to kind of et everybody
on the same page, if
you already know this
stuff, I apologize.
You'll be a little bored, but
just hang with me here, and
then we'll move on.
At the highest layer, we have
Software as a Service.
That simply describes an
application that requires you
to have a web browser
to access.
That's it.
If I'm a user of Yahoo Mail,
Hotmail, or Gmail, I really
need to have a web browser
to access them.
Unless of course I have a mobile
version, but still it's
not running on your server,
in your home, in
your lab, or whatnot.
You're not maintaining your
own mail server at home
because you've decided that,
hey, you know what?
That's too much trouble.
I've got to run an IMAP
server, SMTP server.
I really don't want to
do that in my house.
I just trust one of these
third party vendors like
Yahoo, Microsoft, or Google
to handle my email for me.
You are outsourcing your email
to a third party vendor, and
that's what those apps are.
Of course, you notice
that you don't have
control over that code.
If you find a bug in Yahoo Mail,
or in Google Apps, or
something like that, you really
need to file a ticket
because it's the vendor's
responsibility to manage that
source code.
Same thing goes for
Salesforce, and
NetSuite, and all those.
Those are all Software
as a Service.
At the very bottom
layer, we have
Infrastructure as a Service.
That's where you just
say, you know what?
I'm going to outsource
everything because I just
don't want to have anything
on premise.
I don't want to maintain my
own labs, my own machines.
I'm just going to rent
hardware from Amazon,
Microsoft, Google,
or whomever.
So I'm getting virtual
machines, or
I'm renting big disks.
And hopefully as a paying
customer, I'm going to get all
those necessary things that I
must have in order for those
services to work, like
networking, power, and
cooling, right?
It would be really boring if you
rented something and you
had none of those three.
You'd be stupid.
So those are the things that
you get when you use
Infrastructure as a Service.
Now those two levels people
are pretty familiar with.
The one that's still somewhat of
a mystery to people is the
middle one, which is Platform
as a Service.
This is where you've got
something like infrastructure,
but you've got something
a little bit more.
And the thing is, it's
really a lot more.
If you're renting virtual
machines and disk, there are
certain things that you have
to be responsible for in
addition to your application.
You've got to worry about
the operating system.
Do I run Windows Server?
Do I run Linux?
If I choose Linux, which
distribution?
And then once you choose a
distribution, you've got to
pick kernel version.
Those decisions have to be made,
then you have to decide
what web server, what database
server, do I go with a
traditional LAMP stack or
do I need something more
specialized?
So all those decisions have to
be made at the same time as
you working on your app, and
those things are problems for
every app, not just yours.
So that's called cross cutting
functionality.
So what Platform aims to do is
to solve all those problems
for you and let you
focus on your app.
You don't worry about the
operating system or the
database server, any
of that stuff.
The Platform takes care
of that stuff for you.
Of course App Engine is the
subject of tonight's talk, but
there's other, similar
systems.
Azure from Microsoft.
There's Cloud Foundry
from VMware.
They've spun that off.
OpenShift from Red Hat.
So we've got these three
layers defined.
And then of course in between
each layer is a bunch of gray
area, and so you can
see the gray area.
Typically, it's something like
a database type of service or
some sort of data service.
You can think of it as Data
as a Service if you want.
So like BigQuery, Cloud SQL,
those are all querying
mechanisms.
Google Translate, Google
Prediction.
There's also the Amazon
databases, and also Microsoft
SQL Azure as well.
So most of them are
database services.
They're more than infrastructure
because you're
getting more than hardware,
but you don't quite get an
application platform that you
can actually build apps on.
Those are building blocks.
This grey area are building
blocks that you can use in
your application, but they
themselves do not constitute
an application.
And then similarly, between
SaaS and Platform, we have
products like Google Apps Script
And force.com, which
while they are kind of like a
platform because they can host
Apps Script apps or force.com
apps, they're really tied to a
particular vendor's
information.
Like force.com you use to build
apps to connect to your
Salesforce data.
Google Apps Script you use to
write JavaScript apps to
access to your data
in Google Apps.
So those are middle,
gray areas.
They're more than PaaS, but
they're not quite SaaS either.
They themselves provide you
the ability to code, so
there's some kind
of coding there.
The other cool thing, I think,
that makes Platform really
powerful is that at the
software level, I just
mentioned a minute ago that you
don't have access to that
source code.
You can't control it.
But with Platform, you do.
It is your code.
In fact, you can think of it as
you're using Platform as a
service, platforms, to create
the next SaaS app with.
That's really what
you're doing.
Your writing an app so that
other people can access it
online, and they don't have
access to your source code.
Everybody in the
same page now?
You all know which levels we're
at so that when you get
into these hallway
conversations, you really know
what you're talking about?
All right.
Because I think that's
really important.
Let's talk about Google
Cloud Platform.
The Cloud Platform encompasses
things at
the lower two levels.
So of course, Google Apps
you can't code.
For all you guys who are
developers, this is where you
can do the coding, down here.
So what is the Cloud Platform?
The Cloud Platform is our
integrated platform that
provides multiple services,
a compute service, stored
service, and application
services.
I'll show you that on the
diagram in the next slide.
I already mentioned that it
covers just the platform and
the infrastructure levels.
It really is just an extension
of our own infrastructure.
Before any of this ever existed,
Google had to do all
this stuff to run
our business.
We had to make things scale.
We had to make search
fast and reliable.
We had to make Gmail work.
We had to make YouTube work.
All those things we actually
built for ourselves, and so
now we're basically creating
sort of like external
endpoints so that you can access
the same technologies
that we've built.
And if you're running on a
Google network, now you have
access to other Google services
and tools beyond the
Cloud Platform.
Things like Google Apps, and
Course Builder, Apps Script,
and things like that.
I'll mention some of those
tonight as well.
And the best part is as we
make improvements to this
cloud, to make it better, to
make it faster, to add more
features, guess what?
You guys get access
to those, too.
Of course, we have to write
the endpoints for them and
give you the APIs, but as we
find that certain features we
think will be valuable to
users, or you tell us if
things are valuable, then we
will go ahead and make those
available for you as much
as we possibly can.
So that's really what the main
idea of the Platform is.
I mentioned there were three
different pillars
of the Cloud Platform.
The compute side, so that's
Compute Engine and App Engine.
The storage stuff, which is
where you put all your data,
whether they be files
or pure data.
And also application services.
These are the three
major areas.
Also I didn't want to leave
this out, but you guys
probably already know that
Google has a worldwide
network, so I don't really
need to spend
much time on this.
Everything is well-connected.
They're all fiber.
Everything's very, very quick
even to really remote
parts of the world.
I think that the last mile is
usually where the bottlenecks
always are.
So, bottom line is
that we use this
cloud to run our business.
We want this business
to keep going.
We want it to be successful.
We want our apps and our
services to be reliable, to be
quick, to be secure.
We want to give that to you
guys, so use what we use.
Build your software, run your
business in the same place
that we do with the same scale,
performance, security,
and value that we built
for ourselves.
Really.
I mean, we built for ourselves,
and guess what?
Now we want to share
that with you.
Take advantage of all the years,
all the man hours that
we put into making the dog
gone thing scalable, and
reliable, and fast,
and secure.
In fact, I think personally that
scalability is the most
difficult and the most expensive
thing to build.
Because you got to hire really
smart people, you got to
really know how to measure
performance as far as
minimizing the latency for your
app, being able to handle
sabotage and DoS attacks,
and things like that.
All those things we've
had to already worry
about and try to solve.
And we got a really nice quote
from "Wired" magazine almost a
year ago that really describes
how we see our data centers as
at the core part of the company,
and we really want to
make some of these services
available to you guys.
So tonight, we're going to
focus on one part of the
compute pillar, and that
is App Engine.
That's really the background
I wanted to set.
That's the backdrop.
Moving forward, let's tell
you about App Engine.
If you were to build another app
today, you got to do the
LAMP stack.
You're probably going to have
some sort of database with a
master and a bunch of slaves.
Probably going to have a bunch
of front end web servers, and
then you're going to have some
proxies to do caching and
things like that.
But a couple things are missing
from this diagram,
which is what about failures?
What about traffic problems
and scaling?
I don't even think my app shows
up in this picture.
This is just the foundation
that my app is
going to run on.
So there's a lot of things
that you need to set up.
And even if you've got things
perfectly done-- you've got
this smart network architect,
he built everything
perfectly--
that still doesn't mean that
everything is going to work
just right.
So all those problems that I
mentioned, you do outsource
all of your hardware and
get infrastructure.
So yes, I got virtual machines,
I got storage.
But I already mentioned you
have to worry about the
operating system, and then the
web server, and then the
database server.
But I didn't even mention
configuration files, load
balancing, monitoring,
reporting, software licenses,
patches, upgrades,
license fees.
All those things are things that
you need to worry about
in addition to your
application.
So the reason why App Engine
exists was because six, seven
years ago, a couple of smart
people at Google felt that it
took too long time to go from
concept and code all the way
to having an app that's
available live around the
world, and that was the problem
you're trying to solve.
And so hopefully, all these
little, brown boxes can be
dropped into one large box
called App Engine, and
hopefully we'll give you
familiar tools that you can
use like Python, Java, PHP, and
Go that you can actually
build these applications without
changing your skill
set too much.
The main idea is to let you
focus on your app, not have to
worry about the sys admin stuff,
not have to worry about
the networking, the machines,
and all that extra stuff, like
I said, that is cross cutting
in relationship to your app.
Focus on your app.
Let us wear the pagers, and take
care of the system, and
all that kind of stuff.
And so because of that, again, I
want you to not get confused
between App Engine and
infrastructure services.
So I don't want to hear are you
going to use App Engine
versus EC2?
If you really want to make that
kind of a comparison,
then you really should be
talking about let's compare
Google Compute Engine
versus Amazon EC2.
That's probably a more
fair assessment.
Because now both of those are
at the infrastructure level,
and now you can compare them.
But App Engine is a completely
different beast because it
handles so many things
for you.
We're trying to get you to
market faster and not have to
worry about this extra stuff
that may slow you down.
If those four languages aren't
good enough for you, because
we have a JVM, we support a lot
of other popular languages
today, like Scala Ruby.
Those are good alternatives
because we have a JVM.
You can even run Jython,
too, which is Python.
Even though we have a native
Python, I found out a lot of
developers really like to use
Jython because they have a lot
of legacy classes that are
written in Java, and a lot of
their new development is
happening in Python but they
don't want to port everything.
So the nice thing about Jython
is Jython is basically a
Python interpreter that's
written Java so that Python
objects can talk to Java objects
and move things back
and forth because everything
at the bottom level is just
Java bytecode.
So it's a really good solution
for software houses that use
both Java and Python.
One of the other tricky things
about running in the cloud is
you're sitting next to a lot
of other people who are
developers here, but maybe you
might not trust them with your
source code or your data.
It probably wouldn't be great
if you could access other
people's source code
and their data.
And so in order to make things
secure, we require that all of
your applications run in a
restricted environment called
the sandbox.
And in the sandbox, you can
only play with your
sand and your toys.
You can't play with other
people's toys.
This restricted environment
does not permit you to do
certain things, like you can't
create a local file.
You can't open an inbound
socket connection.
You can't make an operating
system call.
All those things are security
hazards, so the system
prevents you from doing
those things.
But the question you may be
asking me is, well, gee, if I
can't open a socket connection,
I can't talk to
another app online, I've got
a pretty useless app.
I can't really do anything if
I can't talk on the network.
Maybe I want to talk
to another app
that's running online.
Maybe I want to send email,
something really simple.
I want to open up port
25 or something.
The thing is, we're
aware of that.
Why would you want that
low level access?
Because you're going to have
to rebuild something that
other people are going to
have the build also.
So why not give you a higher
level API like the email API?
You can use the mail API
and send messages.
Even better is you can actually
have your application
receive inbound email and
process it programmatically.
Similarly, if you have to
execute another app that's
online, there's URL Fetch.
We give you a database.
You can choose either the native
NoSQL datastore, or you
can choose a MySQL compatible
relational database.
You have two choices there.
Of course, all of your data is
distributed globally, so the
rights aren't going to be as
quick as the MySQL server that
you have sitting on the
floor in your office.
It's not going to
be that fast.
Because your data is going to
be global everywhere, if you
want speed, we recommend that
you cache as much as you
possibly can, so use Memcache.
Other services that you can
get access to, we have a
simple Images API where
you can rotate,
resize, crop images.
If you want to store large
audio/video files to serve,
you can use Cloud Storage
for that.
We also provide authentication
service, so either you roll
your own authentication
or you have no OAuth.
Another option you have is you
can require your users to have
Google accounts and have
them sign in with that.
But if you want to be even more
broad and be more open,
we also have Federated Login
which allows you to have your
users log in using OpenID.
So they can log in either with
their Google account, or with
their Yahoo, or AOL,
or WordPress,
or any OpenID provider.
So that gives you some
flexibility there.
Another restriction that I
didn't mention-- oh, the other
one I wanted to talk about was
the Channel API which lets you
maintain connections
to the browser.
And the reason why I'm
mentioning the Task Queue and
the Channel API last is because
one other restriction
that I haven't told you about
yet is you can't hog all of
the resources.
There's other people running
on the same machine as you.
You cannot run for more
than 60 seconds.
When a user at their web browser
hits your app, you
need to respond back to that
user in less than 60 seconds.
As a human, you can to tell
whether or not it's slow by
even one second.
You know that.
So 60 seconds is way long.
But if for some reason you need
to fire off something
that may take a long time, like
you need to talk to other
APIs, the Facebook API, the
Twitter API, or you need to
run a large batch job somewhere
in the background or
elsewhere online, you don't
necessarily have to be
restricted to that 60 seconds
if you don't want to.
An alternative is to
use the Task Queue.
We have different types of Task
Queues, but the one that
I'm going to describe let's
you just fire off those
background tasks using
the Task Queue.
Those things, each individual
task, can run up to 10
minutes, not 60 seconds.
So you have 10 minutes of
execution time there.
And the reason why the Channel
API is here is because if you
fire off a background task,
you really want to respond
back to your user in less
than a second or so.
So you can actually fire off a
task, respond back to your
user, but that doesn't mean
you need to lose all
connectivity with your user.
Maybe you want to tell them
when that thing is done or
when it's ready, or maybe you
want to refresh their web
page, or do something else with
their UI so that they can
tell something's been done.
That's what the Channel
API is.
Because that lets you hold onto
to a connection to the
user's browser, and when that
background job is done, you
can actually send a message
through the Channel API, the
channel that's connected to that
user's browser, and take
whatever action you need to.
So just because you fire up
off a background task or
respond to a user doesn't mean
you have to have bad user
experience.
So these are just nine
of the core APIs.
There's almost 40 of them.
There's way more than I can
put on a slide here.
There's the MapReduce API.
There's the Search API that
lets you index your data,
whether you're searching for
text, or for time stamps, or
for geopoints for lat-long
searching.
So there's lots of other
services that I don't have
listed here, but these are
sort of the main nine.
We give you these higher level
services to make up for what
you can't get because you
don't have the same full
control over the machine
that you used to.
How does it work?
It's very, very similar.
This is not too much
rocket science.
We have front end machines that
get the request, and then
we have App Engine app servers
that run your app.
And whenever they need to talk
to another service, like you
need to request something from
them Memcache or you need to
send something to the datastore,
it fires off those
RPCs to the back end.
They do their work, they get
back to the server, which
responds back to your user.
So it's not exactly rocket
science, but what you don't
see here is the scalability
that's done
automatically for you.
It's autoscaling where you don't
think about how many
instances of your app are up.
You don't really
care, actually.
You just want your app to be
working in responding to your
users, and that's really all you
should be thinking about.
Another thing you don't have
control over is I can't log in
and download my logs.
I can't SSH into my box because
there is no box,
because you've decided to upload
your apps to Google.
Your apps are actually running
in the same data centers, on
the same machines, as what's
running Search, and YouTube ,
and Gmail, and all those
different things.
Those servers you don't
have access to.
And so why would you want to
log in and get your logs?
Well, maybe you want to do some
analysis like what kind
of traffic am I getting?
Have I gone over my
free quota yet?
The team knows this stuff, so we
have a developer's console
that shows you information about
your app that you would
otherwise have to
build anyway.
In fact, everybody that writes
apps should be building
something like this.
But instead, we created for you
on your behalf so that you
don't have to worry about it.
So you can measure
your traffic.
You can your measure
traffic rate.
If you can see the numbers, if
you squint really carefully,
you can see that this app is
averaging about 0.2, and then
the number is requests
per second.
So 0.2 requests a second means
one user like every five
seconds or so.
And then there's a couple of
peaks here, and it looks like
it's peaking about 0.5.
So maybe at the peak
it's getting a
user every other second.
That's not a dead app.
It's not exactly a hard core,
viral app, but it is getting
some traffic.
It is getting some traffic.
So that's one thing
to recognize.
This is a pull down, if you
could probably tell, but you
can pull down a whole bunch
of other charts, too.
Like what's my error
rate for my app?
How many errors am I generating
per second?
Or there's lots of other
different metrics that are
measured graphs that you
can take a look at.
You can also see your
billing settings.
You can see how close am I to
the end of the free quota?
Have I gone over
the free quota?
How much of I budgeted?
How much has it cost me today?
The daily cost, of course,
refreshes every 24 hours.
And we give you lots of knobs
and dials so that is actually
tune your app in its
performance to
control your budget.
This screenshots, I don't know
if you guys recognize this,
but this is from
four years ago.
Today's admin console is way
more complex than this.
There are so many features on it
that I don't really want to
overwhelm you, but this
is the minimum of what
you're going to get.
If you take a look at your admin
console when you get
back to your office or back home
tonight, you'll see that
it has a lot more
features here.
But in this admin console
you can do lots
of different things.
You can check what your
full quota usage is.
Your billing settings,
you can adjust that.
You can set who are your
developers, who can upload new
versions of your app, who can
look at your app, who can
operate in the admin console.
You can take a look at your
data through here.
So there's all kinds of things
that you can do from the admin
console because you don't have
access to the machines.
So we give you this
in lieu of that.
So now we can talk about
some numbers.
Usually when you ask a Google
employee can you tell me how
much this, how much that,
usually we tell you,
sorry, we can't say.
These are actually numbers
we can talk about.
Like how many people
are actually
building App Engine apps?
Well, there's more than a
quarter of a million people
who are developing apps, and
this is on a monthly basis.
Of these 3 million active
developers, they have more
than 3 million active
applications.
"Active" means not the Hello
World you tried two and a half
years ago that no one's
checking out anymore.
These are apps that are either
getting traffic and/or are
getting new versions being
uploaded, people checking into
the admin console,
things like that.
Active.
In fact, half of all the IP
addresses that are in
circulation out there, public IP
address, will touch an App
Engine server every
single week.
That's not to say so
that App Engine
runs half of the internet.
It's that half of IP addresses
touch an App Engine server.
What that really means is you
may be using App Engine and
not know it.
And I'll give you some
examples of when
that may be the case.
How about those big numbers?
If you were to put all 3
million of these active
applications together, how
many page views or
application--
HTTP hits do you think we get
on a daily basis, per day?
Any ideas?
How about 7.5 billion?
And in fact, all the apps put
together in a month will
generate 4 and 1/2 trillion
datastore requests, and this
is in the native NoSQL
datastore.
This is not with the MySQL
relational database.
That's a lot of traffic,
without going
down as well, either.
So those are some of the
googley-sized numbers.
Oh, by the way, you know how
we release products, they
always come out as beta first?
The thing that actually caused
us to get over that and become
an official product is when
we passed a billion.
That attracted the attention
of some of our vice
presidents.
So they really won't notice
you until you do something
like a googley number like
that, a billion.
And so of course, Google
products generally have one or
two different ends.
One is not so good.
The other one is a wine
and cheese party.
So when we got the wine and
cheese party, that was a good
sign that App Engine
was on its way to
become an official product.
And as of November of 2011,
almost two years ago, it is an
official product, which means
it has to go through our
normal deprecation policy
and things like that.
So those are some numbers.
There's a bunch of users.
I can't put them all
on the page.
There's just too many
to list, but I will
discuss a couple of them.
Some are big names that you'll
recognize, but while it may be
true that most of Khan Academy
runs on App Engine, not all of
Best Buy or MTV or Evite
runs on App Engine.
But some of them run a good
chunk of stuff, a good amount
of traffic sent our way.
I'm going to talk about a
variety of different apps from
different developers.
Some are old, some are
new, but just to
give you a rough idea.
I want to give you an idea of
the scaling, and then I want
to tell you a little bit more
about current apps that are
being built.
Some of the older ones, one of
them is I want to talk about
long-term scaling.
We've got this app that's been
around since the early days of
App Engine.
It's called BuddyPoke.
And it's a cutesy app.
It's got avatars and
stuff like that.
It's probably not for
my age group.
me, basically.
But they have a lot of users,
and in 2011 they actually had
more than 64 million
registered users.
The 62 number is from 2010.
So the year after, they had
more than 64 million
registered users.
What you should be thinking is,
oh, that means they have
more than 64 million objects
in their datastore.
That's what you really
should be thinking.
Other people go, oh, I'm
really skeptical.
I don't care about
registered users.
Tell me how many people use
this app every single day.
So back in 2011 when MySpace
was around, Facebook and
MySpace, I'd probably say that
most of the traffic from
MySpace has probably gone
Facebook by now.
So roughly I'd say 5 and 1/2
to 6 billion daily, active
users, people that log into
the app every day.
So that's not too bad.
So that's one type of scaling,
just a large,
slowly growing datastore.
Another type of scaling comes
from a different company
called Gigya, and what they do
is they build apps for very
specific purposes, like some
sporting event or a Hollywood
movie promo.
Their apps typically get no
traffic, then all off a sudden
they get an obscene
amount of traffic.
And then all off a sudden it
dies, and then they go back
and reskin that app for
another purpose.
Do you remember that picture
that I showed you from the
admin console where they were
getting 0.2 requests per
second and then peaking about
0.5 requests per second?
If you look very carefully
at these numbers, they're
slightly bigger than
0.2 and 0.5.
This number is 400.
So in your head, you're thinking
400 users per second
accessing this app.
So it has no traffic, and then
presumably some PR goes out
for the event, and then
people go to the
website, blah blah blah.
So it actually climbs
pretty quickly.
I'd say within half an hour,
it climbs to 800 QPS.
That's 800 browsers submitting
a request to
this app every second.
Then the event looks like it
starts right here, and then it
ramps up really, really
quickly now.
And during the course of the--
it appears to be about an
hour's worth.
In the course of one hours,
it peaks at pretty
much exactly 1,600.
That's 1,600 users per second
accessing this app without
having it go down.
And then you can see probably
that the event ends just
around here.
And this event was, if I
remember correctly, a relief
for the Haiti earthquake.
It was a benefit for people
who survived and to help
things out.
And so that was one example of
an app that they did just to
give you an idea
of the traffic.
So 1,600 users, that's a lot of
requests, but let's say we
want to get bigger, because
this is Google.
We want to get bigger, better,
more traffic, more traffic.
And so beyond short-term
scaling, I need to talk to you
about royal scaling.
This is the extreme case now.
So we all know that the wedding
happened a couple
years ago, that's fine.
It's finally had a
result recently.
But their blog was an App Engine
app, and on the wedding
day, they got up to 2,000
QPS, 2,000 users per
second hitting the app.
And the YouTube live stream was
also on App Engine app.
Its number was slightly
more than that.
They had 32,000 requests
per second.
32,000 users per second
hitting this app.
And that's a really
giant number.
And when the kiss happened, or
the double kiss happened, it
peaked at another 10K
on top of that.
So 42 KQPS, which are four
letters I don't usually say
next to each other.
It's an obscene amount
of scaling.
This ain't your daddy's cheap
PHP hosting service.
That is not the purpose of it,
even though App Engine
supports PHP now.
The purpose is to build
something like this
that won't fall down.
That is really what
you're getting.
If you want cheap PHP hosting,
that's fine,
you can go for that.
It's going to be cheaper,
honestly.
You're trying to create the next
startup that goes viral,
and App Engine is a proper,
appropriate product for that.
So far, all the apps I've
mentioned have been web-based,
but guess what?
Your UI could be
somewhere else.
It doesn't have to
be web-based.
You could create a mobile app.
That's where your UI is.
And if you want to give your
users a good experience,
you're going to have to store
some data somewhere.
If you're a game creator, you
make this awesome game, people
work really hard, compete
with their
friends, get a high score.
If they're students, and they
know they go to a party,
things happen to their phones.
If they have to replace their
phone, get a new one, download
your app again, log
into your app.
If they don't see those same
high scores, they're probably
not going to play your app
anymore, because that's not a
great user experience.
You really want to offload some
of this stuff to the back
end service, have this data
stored elsewhere, so that
people can check their high
scores from their phone or
from their desktops or whatnot,
or tablet, or whatever.
So you really want to be putting
things into the cloud.
You have a similar
choice if you're
building a back end anyway.
Either you're going to be doing
it yourself and hosting
it yourself, or you can rely on
a service like App Engine
which all you need is HTTP to
access your app and give your
users a much better
experience.
And this leads to what are some
of those apps I may be
using that are App Engine apps
but I don't know it?
Maybe I want to check
the news.
There's an app called Pulse.
I don't know if anybody's a user
of it, but they're a very
popular app.
They're one of the top apps in
the iTunes store, as well as
in the Google Play store.
And they got a bunch of awards
in 2011 when they launched,
but still going strong.
They have apps for Android,
for iOS, and for Kindle.
They have more than 30 million
users, and people read more
than 10 million stories a day.
They get thousands of
QPS just like the
non-royal wedding app.
And again, more than one million
requests every day.
And they were kind enough to
write a story for us in our
blog back in 2011.
But we really want to make
mobile development easy, and
so we have a tutorial and sample
code to help you get
started with that.
And then I'll also mention
another tool that App Engine
has that is made for you to
start to build your mobile
version of your app easier,
so I'll talk about that a
little later on.
There are other apps online that
you may not be aware is
App Engine.
Even if you play the web version
of Angry Birds, that
web page has to be served
by something.
It's served by App Engine.
And those aren't
the only apps.
There's plenty more.
As far as modern day apps are
concerned, we have Snapchat.
I don't know if any of you guys
are familiar with this
service, but it's like
Instagram but
the pictures disappear.
So if you do something naughty
over the weekend, you take a
picture you want to share with
you friends but you want it to
have a TTL, that's
a snapshot is.
It's a sharing of images that
all expire, so the proof of
your debauchery is not going
to be long-lived.
They serve 150 million
snaps a day.
They're a big App Engine user.
I don't know if you guys
have played SongPop.
It's a very popular app mobile
as well as on Facebook.
Basically it's name that tune.
As fast as you can, in the
shortest amount of time.
You guys probably can't be me.
But along with App Engine,
they also use
Google Cloud Storage.
They serve more than 18
terabytes a day of music.
They have 80 million registered
users with more
than 1 million daily
active users.
So that's another.
These are more modern day apps
that are using the Google
Cloud Platform.
So now let's make developing
the mobile
version of your app easy.
You've got an App Engine app.
If you code in a very specific
way, you can access Google
Cloud Endpoints.
What Cloud Endpoints is, is that
it takes all your code
that you've put in nice,
convenient places.
It builds all the boilerplate
for you, from your app, but
will also compile and give you
boilerplate code in Java for
your Android apps.
So it'll give you Objective
C code for your iOS apps.
It'll also generate some
JavaScript if you want a
mobile web version
of your app.
The purpose of this tool is to
make it easy for you to build
APIs to your back office, the
back end version of your app,
that's running on App Engine
and to get you started with
the front end.
So you can worry about the front
end, but the back end is
taken care of for you.
There's also a tutorial and some
sample code that you can
here as well.
So you can watch a five minute
video, and then you can
download the code and
get playing with it.
So that's the Cloud Endpoints.
As you can see, based on
everything I've run through so
far, they're just a few examples
of App Engine apps.
There's so many more that I
don't have the time to talk
about them.
Believe it or not, App Engine's
really popular with
dating sites.
Who knew?
Similarly, it's a very great
platform to have students
learning how to code web apps
and mobile apps in schools.
I'll talk about pricing later,
but we have a pretty
generous free tier.
And so you can even use it in
research projects, or in back
the school IT staff can use it
to create apps to help operate
the school.
Same goes for enterprise.
You can build enterprise
apps with this thing.
It's not just for web apps.
It's for all kinds of apps.
So those are just some of the
popular use cases that we've
seen so far.
Now to the management
set of slides.
Obviously, when I go talk to
CIOs and CTOs, besides are
there any educational discounts,
another FAQ I get
is what about vendor lock in?
Is Google trying to milk me for
all my money and all my
company's money forever?
You would like to think that.
My question is have you ever
know Google to be good at
charging money for anything?
I can't seem to find places
to pay Google
for anything, actually.
So maybe more drive storage?
Maybe more Gmail storage?
I don't know.
Anyway, to me it's
kind of hard.
we're?
Not really after that.
We're actually after a vibrant
web ecosystem.
And if there's more people
online, more people using
apps, there's probably going
to be more people clicking
ads, and that's how
I get my paycheck.
So that's what we're
really after.
We're not trying to milk
you for all your money.
So what's locking?
If you're not familiar with
this term, it's basically
where you have a system that
makes it really hard or
impossible for you to move or
your data off of that system
and perhaps move to a
competitive system.
Does it apply to App Engine?
Well, kind of yes
and kind of no.
And so when they ask that
question, they're trying to
make it sound like, oh,
Google's the bad guy.
But I actually completely flip
the tables over, because my
response is, wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Don't you want to take advantage
of Google, of all
the R&D and all the man hours
that we put in to make our
system scalable, make it
fast, make it reliable?
You really want to give your
apps that stuff without having
you build it yourself.
So you're trying to take
advantage of Google.
But the thing is, since we came
up with the system, of
course we're going to
be the first ones to
develop an API for it.
So yes, when the system first
came out, you had to use
Google APIs.
But really it's not in our DNA
to try and milk people for all
their money.
And in fact, I'm very happy to
say that our director publicly
responded to people's criticisms
of our system
trying to do the
lock in thing.
He pushes back just as strong
as I do, and I'm glad that
we're on the same
page on this.
So really, you should spend
some time, take
a look at his post.
It's really worthwhile reading
to hear from senior management
of App Engine, what their
perspective is.
Just don't listen to
me, the mouthpiece.
You really got to hear
it from management.
So, you're trying to take
advantage of our
infrastructure.
Do we need to write
against the APIs?
Maybe.
Does this make sense?
Like you're trying to take
advantage of Google, right?
So even with all this stuff,
we are still trying
to fight lock in.
What are some of the
different ways?
Well, do you have to
use Google APIs?
Not anymore.
Do you have to learn
new skills?
You have to learn some new
skills, but we really don't
want to have you start
from scratch.
If you know how to write a
servlet in Java or you know
how to use JSP, if you really
want to do that, you could
take your skills
to App Engine.
If you are a Python developer,
and you don't want to use the
web framework that comes with
the SDK, you can use Django,
or web2py, or Tipfy, Flask,
Bottle, Pyramid,
any of those things.
Those things, you can run
apps on App Engine.
You'll have to probably
downloaded another piece of
software to make it happen,
but it can happen.
I already mentioned earlier,
you can choose between our
native NoSQL datastore, or you
can choose our relational
MySQL compatible datastore.
Maybe you don't want to
do any SQL at all.
You just want to do objects.
Well, if you program
in Django, you can
use Django's ORM.
If you use the MySQL compatible
Google Cloud SQL,
you can use Django pretty much
straight up and just make sure
your settings file's
really the only
thing you have to change.
But you can also use it with our
non-relational datastore,
too, if you download a third
party app called
Django-nonrel.
Similarly, if you're a Java
user, and you're familiar with
JDO or JPA, you can use
those ORMs as well.
Or you can use something
a little
lower level, like Objectify.
That works perfectly.
All of our SDKs are open source,
so if you really want
to you can reverse engineer
APIs if you want.
All of our Java APIs, we try to
make them stick as close to
the JSR standards as
much as possible.
With Python, we pretty much just
have you write against
the standard library.
We also give you datastore
bulkloader to easily upload or
download all of your data.
Now if you have a lot of data,
it may not be the world's
fastest thing, but you can put
your data in and take it out
at any time.
And even then, maybe you're in
a situation where you're
working for an employer where
you can't have Google hosting
apps or data.
It just must run in your
own data center.
There are actually open source
back end systems that claim to
be fully APi-compatible with
Google App Engine.
In Python, there's
two of them.
One is AppScale,
one is Typhoon.
In Java, it's CapeDwarf.
You can actually run these in
your own data centers on
premise or in your CO-LOs.
So that way you're completely
free of Google.
You can take any of your App
Engine apps that you wrote
before, that you ran on Google
before, but you can now run
them on your own.
And here's an even
funnier story.
Well, maybe it's not funny, but
to me I think it's funny.
Because AppScale is actually
project from UC Santa Barbara,
which is where I went to grad
school, but I had nothing to
do this project because
it came afterwards.
And because they're a university
research project,
they actually applied for a
research grant from the Google
research team.
And guess what?
They won!
They won a significant award
to build this thing.
So in a sense, you could say
that Google is funding its own
competition because we are
so against lock in.
So it's really not part of
the company's DNA to do
that type of stuff.
It's just not part
of the culture.
So that's lock in.
Now of course, we have to get
into pricing because we're the
management set of
slides, right?
It's free.
We have a pretty generous
free tier.
And when I say generous, I mean
that you could probably
run your small business or your
church website off of it
without having to ever
pay Google a penny.
And if you do go over your
free quota, then you
just pay per use.
Whatever you use beyond the free
quota, whatever is pay
per use, like if you use a
little bit more networking, I
think it's like $0.12 per gig
of data that you send more.
So you have all these little
incremental costs.
If you want to have support,
you can go for one of the
premiere services.
There's more information on
pricing at the link there, but
with premiere pricing, you
can get some support.
So if you need to get a response
back in a certain
timeframe or whatnot,
you can do that.
So it starts at $150.
If you do any kind of paid
service, you'll get an SLA,
which is a guaranteed uptime.
And of course, there's extra fee
for custom things that you
want, like maybe your own domain
SSL, things like that.
But like I said, you
can pretty much
get started for free.
Again, more management stuff.
Some folks are worried
about compliance.
We are SAS 70 compliant as
well as complaint to its
replacement, which SSAE 16 and
the international version of
that, ISAE 3402, and
we're also ISO 27K
compliant as well.
Some folks also have a
restriction that your data in
your apps must be hosted within
certain geographical
boundaries, so you can actually
choose to have your
apps be based in the US or
based out of the EU.
We're expanding our global
footprint, so we started with
North America-based, and now
we've moved to Europe, and at
some point we'll hit other parts
of this globe as well.
The roadmap is available online
for you here, and some
of the things that we're working
on-- let me get a
drink here--
include support for
Java Servlet 3.0.
Migration of Blobstore, so we're
migrating everything
over to Google Cloud Storage
from the old Blobstore that we
had originally.
And I think one of the most
exciting things that we have
in the pipeline is a VM-oriented
Runtime.
VM Runtime means you can have
App Engine-managed back ends.
We use Compute Engine VM, so
if you have code that can't
run within App Engines normal
restrictive environments, you
can actually spin off some of
that code to have it run in a
VM on Compute Engine.
So that's pretty exciting.
And of course, deeper
integration with Compute
Engine itself, as well as other
cloud services I'll
mention briefly in a moment.
So that's what's
on the roadmap.
By the way, we're not really
good at vaporware either.
So if it is on the roadmap and
it's published on the website,
that means there's at least one
engineer working on it.
So code is happening.
So you're excited about
App Engine, hopefully.
You're ready to get starts?
Where I go?
What do I do?
If you want to read more about
product information, in other
words, the marketing
page, you can go to
cloud.google.com/products, and
you'll find App Engine there.
If you're a developer, you want
to immediately to start
checking out the docs
and downloads.
Go to developers.googl
e.com/appengine.
If you want to start creating
App Engine apps already,
appengine.google.com.
If you want help from experts
on anything technical
including App Engine, obviously
Stack Overflow is
the way to go, but we have
specific tags for each of our
Cloud products.
So if you want to ask an App
Engine question, you can find
the App Engine tag.
Same goes for our other
Cloud as well.
And not only are there experts
in the field that look at them
and answer questions, but also
Google engineers will look at
them and answer questions,
too.
So everybody's participating.
There's a blog that you should
follow, and we also have
social endpoints which are our
Twitter account and our
Google+ account.
Some of you guys may be
teachers or you may be
trainers, or you may be tech
leads that want to train your
employees how to use
our cloud, so what
about teaching materials?
Guess what?
We have that too, because if
you're interested in teaching
App Engine at work or if you
work at a university and want
to start teaching it, do you
think you have to go and
investigate App Engine from
scratch, come up with your own
examples, come up with your
own teaching materials?
You used to have to worry about
that, but I took care of
that for you.
I and a bunch of co-workers on
the Cloud team have built a
bunch of classes.
You can see they're
all categorized
according to product.
Some of them are beginning to
become cross-product now as
well, too, so you can actually
learn how to use multiple
Google APIs simultaneously.
So we're slowly--
and I emphasize "slowly"--
adding new things every day, but
I try to get the teams to
refresh their material to
keep things up to date
and things like that.
And is currently just static
content, but we're going to
try and do more, like add more
slide decks, add videos, and
things like that.
So those things are all
forthcoming, so kind of keep
your eyes and ears tuned.
But at least there's some
foundation there in case you
are a trainer or you're
a TL of some sort.
I mentioned earlier there's a
way to get started with App
Engine without any downloads
whatsoever, and that is the
Cloud Playground.
So just go to
cloud-playground.appspot.com.
And what you'll get is you'll
get a list of projects that
you can clone, and you
can clone anything.
Here I've called the basic
Hello World app which you
would get if you downloaded the
SDK anyway, but I'm in a
browser that I have no other
connectivity to anything
except for this website.
I can bring up App
Engine code.
I can edit it.
See, it's printing
Hello World now.
If I go and fix the code, like
maybe I add an h1 tag and
change the Hello World to "Hello
Y'all" and click the
little green Run button, I can
actually see the change
reflected in an iframe
down below.
So you actually pretend you're
doing App Engine development.
You can pretty much do all the
Getting Started tutorial
directly in a browser window
from the Cloud Playground.
So I really encourage you guys
who are really, really new to
this, if you're not sure you
want to go and download the
SDK yet and play with it,
really try this out.
Because it doesn't cost
you anything.
You can create projects,
delete projects.
We have a whole bunch of
projects you can clone.
So if you were looking for
something very specific, try
and find a project that closest
meets the needs that
you have, and then clone that.
Change the code, tweak the code,
do whatever you want.
And then one thing that's
missing is there's no Download
Zip File button so that all
the code that you do play
around with, you can actually
take it with you, and you can
download the SDK, run it on
that, and then you can choose
to upload all that to
production, to Google, if you
want as well.
So it's a really flexible tool,
fun, and we're adding
new features to it every day.
So that's the Cloud
Playground.
And that's really all I wanted
to say about App Engine, so
let's move on to the last piece,
which is the other
Cloud components.
Of course, I'm going to talk
about the Google Cloud
Platform more, because that's
really the main product that
we have now.
App Engine is just a sub-product
of that group, so
I want you to become more
familiar with what all those
other products are.
And then we'll talk about other
services and software
that Google has that's
available to you.
App Engine is really the gateway
to getting to other
cloud services.
I mentioned that you have
access to a relational
database which is the MySQL
compatible Google Cloud SQL.
If you choose to use the native
NoSQL datastore, that
is now available externally
to you.
It's the Cloud Datastore.
We have Compute Engine, so if
you run virtual machines,
they're there.
Cloud Storage is also
another entry point.
That's where you basically
put all of your data.
It's the large, big disk.
Some people get confused between
Google Drive and
Google Cloud Storage, because
Google Drive is also a form of
cloud storage.
The main difference is Google
Drive lives sort of within the
apps universe.
Which you can also use App
Engine to create apps for you
Google Apps domain, too.
But back to the question
about Google Drive
versus Cloud Storage.
Drive is more used for apps,
for your documents, for
sharing with other people, for
collaborations and for syncing
to multiple devices.
Cloud Storage is for your 5
terabytes of data that you're
not going to put in
Google Drive.
It's not for a document.
It's for your data warehouse.
So that's pretty much the main
difference between the two.
At the very bottom layer, they
may all use the same Google
technologies in the end, but
their purposes are different.
So I just wanted you guys to
be sure of the difference
between the two, especially if
somebody else asks you that.
We also have Google Translate,
Google BigQuery, and
Prediction.
So let's talk about some
of these other
Cloud Platform products.
Let's just say you can't
run within App Engine.
I need to have a socket.
I need to have an inbound socket
because I have some HR
apps that are talking through
the firewall.
I need to have that.
So you VMs.
And so Compute Engine
are on-demand VMs.
We support Red Hats,
CentOS, Debian.
You can have between one
and eight cores.
You can have between nearly
2 to 6 and 1/2
gigs of RAM per core.
And when you create your virtual
machines, they all run
on a private network, so they're
actually talking to
each other without
having internet
traffic get in the way.
And you can specify whether
certain machines have an
endpoint that is accessible from
the public internet, or
you can just choose not to.
You can create your own
subnetwork within that.
Can create firewalls with it.
There's various types
of storage.
All VS will get a local scratch
or ephemeral disk 400
gigs in size.
There's also the awesome
persistent disk because your
local scratch, ephemeral disk
will come and go with your VM.
So if you bring up VMs and bring
them down, those scratch
disks will go away.
But maybe you have a
distribution with all the
packages that you want on it,
and you want all your machines
to use the same one but you
don't want to have to download
all those packages every
time you create a VM?
Put them all on persistent disk,
because persistent disk
will survive the comings and
goings of VMs, and you can
mount them on multiple
VMS as well, too.
Mostly read only, of course,
but that's the power of
persistent disk.
And then we also talked about
Google Cloud Storage, which is
the large-scale storage stuff.
There's three different ways
for you to get to your VMs.
You can use our command line
tool, you can use a web-based
interface, or you can
programmatically access your
VMs via REST API.
You can create VMs, you
can destroy VMs,
all using JSON payload.
Just sent it over,
it'll do it.
You can track progress.
Lots of cool stuff about
Compute Engine.
I think it's a really good
alternative for people who are
used to only getting VMs from
one or two vendors.
Now you have another choice.
GigaOM published a blog post
from Scalr, and they did
research against one of the
competition, and it seems that
Google Compute Engine has
pretty good latency.
We have a fatter pipe.
And one of the coolest things
is the instances are really,
really quick.
Generally, when you create a VM
on Compute Engine, you can
SSH into it in about
half a minute.
They really come up fast.
And they go down quickly
as well, too.
So definitely explore that.
If you're using VMs from other
vendors, you should really
give it a shot and do
your own benchmarks.
Don't necessarily listen to us
or from a third party vendor
like Scalr.
But it's good, at least, they're
a third party, and
they're not owned by Google
or something like that.
But you guys should definitely
do your benchmarks, too.
And we want to hear it.
Please send me any reports
on any bugs you find, any
features that you're
looking for, any
success stories you have.
I'm very happy to send out
t-shirts to people.
I'm sure you're happy to receive
t-shirts as well,
because most developers, who
live off of t-shirts.
My companies all cloth me, much
to the dismay of my wife.
But, yeah, anyway
I'll be happy to
send you guys a shirt.
Some other things.
We already talked about
cloud storage as well.
Very fast, scalable, highly
available object store.
As soon as you write an object
and get acknowledgment back
from Google, anybody can
read it, so it's strong
consistency.
Very flexible authentication.
We use OAuth, and you can have
access control lists to
determine whether it's an
individual, a group, whoever
can get access to
your objects.
You can access it from REST API,
through App Engine's API.
Really, the Cloud Storage client
library, Web UI, or
command line.
Cloud SQL, I already
talked about that.
That's our MySQL compatible
relational database in the
cloud, also accessible
from App Engine or
externally via JDBC.
We also have the Cloud
Datastore.
I mentioned that is our NoSQL
database built at Google scale
using a very lo2-level
interface.
You access it via HTTP.
And If you are familiar with
the native NoSQL datastore
from App Engine, that's
what this is as well.
Many of you probably already
know what Google Translate is,
but guess what?
You can actually access it
programmatically, so you can
write bilingual apps or apps
that do translations as well
also using a familiar
REST-type interface.
A couple other ones.
There's Google BigQuery.
This is where you can issue a
SQL query across multiple
terabytes of data, something
you can't quite do with a
relational database today.
And if you can, you may have to
have a relational database
that's sharded multiple ways,
and you have to do your own
manual MapReduces to be able
to get that data to a size
that can be digested
by your users.
Or it may take an extremely
long time to run those
queries, so with BigQuery you
can actually issue SQL-like
requests to BigQuery on multiple
terabytes of data and
get results back in seconds.
Not hours, and not days.
It is very, very fast, and it's
great no matter how big
your data is.
So you should really
give it a shot.
In fact, we created a cool
little app that you can take a
look at by going to this link
and checking out the tour.
It's a good way to get a sampler
for how BigQuery
works, the kind of data
sets you can use.
And then you can start playing
around with some of our free
public data sets.
You can have fun with finding
out what are the most highly
changed Wikipedia pages, or what
are the most common words
in all of Shakespeare's works?
Or we even have the US
Health and Human
Services neonatality database.
So you can dig deep and ask a
question as precise as what is
the mortality rate for children
born to mothers
between ages 25 and 29 from 1957
to 1962 who were smokers?
You can ask a question like that
to BigQuery, and it'll
give you answer in a very
short amount of time.
So play around with some of
those public data sets.
It's really fun.
And then we also have
Google Prediction.
That is our machine learning
service in the cloud.
So if you're familiar with AI
and machine learning, you may
be familiar with the supervised
learning type of
algorithms, which is what
we support right now.
Basically, the way it works is
you train models and get
predictions.
Some people who have never seen
machine learning before
may think it's magic.
And it kind of is because you're
uploading some data,
and then you're just asking
the Prediction API what is
this, and it'll tell you.
So it's pretty cool
to look at.
You can use it for lots of
different things, like
sentiment analysis, you can do
spam detection, all kinds of
crazy things.
So take a look at that.
So that's really the
Cloud Platform.
So now, onto the rest of the
talk, which are non-cloud
platform products
which you may be
interested in thinking about.
One of them is Fusion Tables.
That's like a combination
between Google Maps and some
kind of spreadsheet.
You can think of them as being
able to take data that's in
one or more spreadsheets and
being able to visualize it.
So something like
election data or
maybe that health data.
When the Haiti earthquake did
happen, it was used to track
which facilities have medical
supplies, what kind of
patients can they accept here
because what kind of medicines
are at these medical
locations.
So you can map all
kinds of things.
If you can put it in a
spreadsheet and you can
visualize it, you can use
Fusion Tables for that.
It's pretty easy to get started,
so you can just take
a look there at that link.
Another tool that we have,
Fusion Tables comes out of the
Fusion Tables team, the Google
Research team there.
Google Research also
built something
called Course Builder.
You probably have no doubt
heard about all these
well-known, massive, open online
courses and learning
content created by Khan Academy,
Udacity, Coursera,
edX, all these big name
vendors, Codecademy.
And maybe you want to offer your
own massive, open, online
course, but you don't want to
have to rely on a third party
vendor like a Udacity
or something.
So the Google Research team
built their own MOOC software,
and they've offered several
courses with it.
The first one is the Power
Searching class.
You didn't know that you could
actually make your searching
better, did you?
Take the class, and you'll find
out lots of different,
new ways of doing
searching that
you've never known before.
But this software Google
Research has built and made it
available as open source.
It runs on App Engine.
Now that you know what App
Engine is, you're very
familiar with it, and you don't
have to worry about
scaling for your massive,
open, online course.
So it's open source.
You can download it there.
You can read our launching blog
post, or you can take a
look at the first class or any
number of our classes that
we're offering through using
Course Builder now.
So now that you can offer
classes online, what about
course registration?
The Google Corporate Engineering
team had to build
an app to help us manage
all of our
internal employee training.
Internally, we call
this gLearn, but
guess what they did?
They took this code-- it runs
on App Engine as well--
and they made it open source.
So a couple years ago, they
announced this at Google I/O,
and they gave a talk on it.
And you can access the code
there, and you can handle
course registrations.
So you could say I could only
take 200 students, or they
need to have manager approval.
Or only employees, no vendors,
contractors,
and things like that.
So there's a lot of business
logic built into it as well.
Instructors will get access to
the course roster, and they
can email them.
So there's lots of different
things that
you can do with it.
And both CloudCourse and Course
Builder, like I said,
are all open source, so you
actually control all the code.
You can customize it
any way you want.
If you want to submit a patch
back, I'm sure people would be
glad to look at it.
So these are two other services
that Google has.
Apps Script.
How many people know what
Apps Script is?
Oh, my gosh.
That's grim.
That's less than 8%.
You have to know what
Apps Script is.
You got to try this, because
it's a crazy amazing.
Apps Script is JavaScript
out of the browser
and in Google's Cloud.
So you know how with Node,
you're already executing on a
Node server, not in a browser?
Well, this is yet another way
you can execute JavaScript.
It's JavaScript that executes in
Google's Cloud, and that we
give you an IDE that you can
actually code in directly.
It's deeply integrated
with Google
Apps and other services.
You can do things like automate
repetitive tasks.
You can manipulate data across
multiple Google apps.
So how does it work?
I'm going to show you four
lines of JavaScript.
Four lines!
That's it.
Four lines of JavaScript code
that touches three different
Google products and is
somewhat useful.
So after this, I'm hoping that
you guys all go and try some
Apps Script as well.
Here are the four lines
of JavaScript.
Before we get started, let's
have one assumption, and that
is I have a Google spreadsheet,
a Google Sheet,
and it has addresses in it.
So we'll start from
that point.
So we've got the spreadsheet.
We've got addresses in it.
Everybody out with that?
Now let's look at the four
lines of JavaScript.
Here's a function.
I'm going to connect to Google
Sheets and get the active
spreadsheet, so that's the
whole spreadsheet.
The second line of code, I'm
going to say, hey, give me
what's in cell A2.
Happens to be the address of
the Google New York office.
Third line, I'm going to call
Google Maps and say create me
a brand new map and drop a pin
at that address that I just
pulled out of the spreadsheet.
Boom.
The last line of code, I'm going
to call Gmail and email
this map to my friend.
Four lines code, three different
Google products.
It's pretty useful.
Now the colleague of mine who
works on the Apps Script,
[INAUDIBLE], he has another
cool example where he'll
connect to Gmail, get the top 10
most recent subject lines,
and he'll go on call Google
Translate and translate them
to Spanish.
So you can do all as a crazy
things touching on various
different Google services.
Pretty useful.
I hope a lot more people raise
their hand the next time I ask
this question.
You guys should really
try it out.
In the past I did a lot of COM
programming where I did a lot
of programming with Microsoft
Office, and Excel, PowerPoint,
things like that.
I used to use COM for that.
This is sort of something
similar for Google Apps.
It's Google Apps Script.
They'll call it GAS.
The team doesn't like that.
Google Apps Script.
Also, Apps has it S on it,
App Engine does not
have an S on it.
Also, App Engine has a space
in between except for the
Twitter hashtag.
All right?
Spell things correctly.
Once you are familiar with
Compute Engine, App Engine,
you now have a foundation to
start touching other Google
APIs and adding way
more interesting
features to your apps.
You can start adding maps using
the Google Maps API, and
we even have mobile versions
of Google Maps API.
So now you can have a mobile app
where your user does not
have to exit your app to launch
Google Maps to use it.
You can actually integrate
Google Maps
features into your app.
You can use the YouTube API.
Channel 7 news up in San
Francisco, they have a YouTube
app where if you're out and
about, you see news happening,
you can actually film it on your
phone, and then you can
use their app.
It will automatically upload
to YouTube, and then send a
link to the TV station and
have you sign all the
necessary releases and all
that kind of stuff.
So that's one way you can
integrate the YouTube API.
You can do all kinds of other
things with the YouTube API.
I don't have time to
talk about it, but
there's also Drive.
Oh, by the way, have you guys
all used the Google Docs
feature or the spreadsheet
feature where multiple people
are all logged in at the same
time, working together?
Google Drive has real time API
so that you could build apps
that let multiple people
log in and use your app
simultaneously.
So you can get the same
goodness as well.
It's pretty awesome.
You can use Go.
You can learn Google TV.
You can do Google+.
You can do Android, of course.
Learn Dart, and Polymer, and all
these cool, new features
that we have.
HTML5.
Google Wallet, you
can monetize.
So really, what I wanted to
present to you tonight was a
foundation of what you can build
your app on top of, and
now all the other APIs or things
that you can use in
those apps that you're
building.
So that's that.
And keep an eye on our blog.
The Developer's Blog is where we
have announcements, pretty
much multiple announcements
every week.
This just happens to be the
one that I did when we
launched the Academy and another
program called the
University Consortium, which
is a place for university
faculty who are teaching with
Google technologies to
collaborate with each other.
Anyway, keep an eye on our blog,
as well as the Google
Cloud blog.
Most of the time, we cross post
as well, too, so you can
keep an eye on both
if you want.
But the Developer's Blog is the
general place where all of
the different product teams
announce the new features and
things like that.
And that is pretty much it,
except for one more thing!
We want to give you guys
some money tonight.
Is Becca here?
Ah, she's taken off.
All right.
We want to give you guys
$2,000, every person.
Not cash.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Is that
an Oprah moment?
WESLEY CHUN: Sorry.
It is an Oprah moment to
be able to use Google
Cloud for no charge.
So developers from affiliated
partners--
the GDG is considered an
affiliated partner--
the Google Cloud marketing team
has come up with a $2,000
package where you actually get
this amount credited towards
Cloud usage.
You can use up to $1,000
for App Engine.
Like I said, the free tier is so
generous you probably won't
be using much of it.
But the other Cloud products
don't currently have a free
tier, so you will be using that
for Google Compute Engine
and all the other Cloud Platform
products that I
talked about.
So for just the GDG members,
apply now,
cloud.google.com/starterpack,
and then use
the promo code gdg-in.
And here is a founder of a
startup that said the starter
pack is pretty cool.
So I think you guys should give
it a shot, play around
with all these different Cloud
Platform products.
Send me questions,
bugs, feature
requests, success stories.
Who knows?
You may be featured on a
Google blog one day.
So talk to me, and the way you
talk to me is you can connect
to me with Google+,
email, Twitter.
I have a blog for my Python work
and also for my books.
I have a website for that.
And then Cloud Platform has
a website, a blog, Twitter
handle, and also a
Google+ as well.
All right?
Thank you very much for
coming, everybody.
I hope you got a
lot out of it.
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: Are there
any questions?
Oh, wait!
I need your help tonight for
those of you who are willing
to stay late because you
want to get a tech
talk and a piano concert.
I'm going to be going
across the street in
about half an hour.
I'm going to be playing
some Chopin.
I'm going to rock some Chopin
across the street, so if you
guys aren't busy.
I can only take x number of you
that Google security will
allow me to take.
But I have a performance that
I'm doing this Saturday?
Or this Sunday.
I can't remember.
Saturday?
And while I can play this in
the dark at home, I need to
have pressure.
So if you're willing to listen
to a Chopin Etudes, just
follow me a little later.
Just hang around.
In the meantime, are there
any questions?
Not about Chopin, but about what
I talked about tonight.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
The first question is if I
want to do something like
OpenCV, is there a direct way
to integrate it in with GAE,
or do I need to go to--
WESLEY CHUN: You can either
go to the mic or I
can repeat the question.
So the question was asking how
do I integrate with OpenCV?
Now I'm not familiar
with OpenCV.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Computer Vision Library.
WESLEY CHUN: Computer
Vision Library, OK.
I think I know what
the question is.
Basically, the question is can
I upload my code and have a
third party library execute
on App Engine?
The answer is yes if
it's pure Python.
It doesn't use any restricted
libraries, and it doesn't have
any C code.
So, no C, so that's going
to be a tricky thing.
I don't know if that's
really bad.
Maybe the whole thing
is C, right?
The whole thing is C, so that's
going to be trickier.
In the past, we've been
more restrictive.
So in the original version of
App Engine with a 2.5 runtime,
we did not have lots
more things.
But with the 2.7 support, we're
trying to relax some of
the security requirements, so
now we actually support NumPy,
we support lxml.
All these things used to be
kind of verboten, but now
they're allowed.
But if it's still C, we still
can't do that yet.
But if it's pure Python,
usually is it's pretty
reasonable.
Good question.
Another question?
Oh, come on!
OK, we'll try you again until
somebody else has
worked up the nerve.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
talk to [INAUDIBLE]
integrating in OAuth together
with Facebook, so you can go
ahead and have one universal
sign in for [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
question.
WESLEY CHUN: All right.
So the question is, we want to
implement single sign on.
It's usually been pretty tricky
with OAuth and all that
kind of stuff.
Yeah, security is always going
to be a bit of an issue, but--
AUDIENCE: You're Google!
You know all about that stuff.
WESLEY CHUN: We do.
We have people that know
a lot about that stuff.
Yeah, that one I'm going to
have to check with our
security team on.
We had the Google Identity
toolkit a little while ago.
I don't know if that's still
correct or not, but I know
another developer advocate on my
team who can better answer
that question than I can.
VAN RIPER: I was going to
say look up Tim Bray.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
It's Tim Bray.
Everybody knows who he is.
Just contact him.
VAN RIPER: B-R-A-Y. Look
him up on Google+.
He talks a lot about
identity-related stuff.
I don't know if his talk was
recorded at OSCON but he's
given a talk [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
Van does remind me.
Tim did give a talk on
identities and authentication
at OSCON, which is the O'Reilly
Open Resource
Convention.
You may be able to get his
slide deck online.
I do not believe they recorded
the talks, thought.
AUDIENCE: Besides the slide
deck, you have the library
that we can use that
does the job?
Or [INAUDIBLE]?
VAN RIPER: Without trying to
be Tim, it's complicated
because I mean if people follow
certain standards, then
there's libraries you can
use that work with those
standards, but there isn't one
standard that everyone is on
board with.
There's the OAuth, different
levels of that, OpenID, and
your flavor of the month.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
I mean, the answer really
is it's complicated
because it's security.
Anybody else?
Question?
Did it just overwhelm
you or something?
Or was this talk to low-level,
you want
to see code or something?
Or what?
I mean, come on.
Boring.
OK!
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Can you
debug remotely?
WESLEY CHUN: Can you
Great question.
Depends what you mean
by debugging.
So a couple of answers
to that.
The SDK that you download, it
does come with the local
development server, so you can
actually run your code locally
on your box and debug there.
As far as debugging remotely,
you'll get error messages.
You'll get exceptions thrown
at you, and you
will get stack traces.
And you can access those
from you admin console.
You can also download
them as well.
Better yet, there is a
tool called Appstats,
A-P-P-S-T-A-T-S, which will
let you actually measure
performance between your app and
the back end services that
you're calling like, Memcache
or task queues or whatever.
You can actually track and
follow what are the
bottlenecks in your code
that's causing
those things to happen.
And so you can refactor your
code so it performs better.
I mean, that's not necessarily
related to bugs, but it's
partially it.
There's also unit testing
frameworks as well for your
App Engine apps, too.
So lots of different tools
that you could use.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How do you develop
beyond one person [INAUDIBLE]?
WESLEY CHUN: The question
is how do you
develop beyond one person?
That's a great question.
Obviously, when you create an
App Engine application, you
create it as yourself, as the
user, but there's a couple
ways of going beyond that.
If you're using a Google Apps
domain, you could specify
people that are in the
apps domain that can
get access your app.
You can also physically opt in
people, but you can send them
an invite to become a developer
on your app.
There's also different roles.
So you could say someone who's
the owner, or someone who's
just a developer, or someone who
can just run the code, or
look at the code, or not do
anything else with it.
So there's multiple
levels of control.
Great question.
Anything else?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Are the servers and
databases compliant with
certain government
confidentiality, stuff like
HIPAA compliance?
WESLEY CHUN: I can't really
speak to other types of
compliance, but the ones that
were mentioned in the talk are
the ones that we
can talk about.
All the other ones we know about
and we're working on,
but we don't have anything
to say today.
For people who are concerned
about that kind of stuff,
typically the use case is if
I've got patient data, and I'm
really worried about HIPAA, what
customers typically do is
they do the encryption
themselves.
It's already encrypted by the
time it comes into Google's
network, so then it's never a
problem for us because we
can't see it.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned how far
you can scale [INAUDIBLE]
stuff like that.
Does it take time to scale
an app [INAUDIBLE]?
If there was a scheduled time
with my app, and 1,000 people
come on my app at that exact
moment, like say, I don't
know, registration
for Google I/O--
WESLEY CHUN: [LAUGHING]
Don't mention that.
There were no bugs in
our software when
registration for I/O--
when it launched.
It was bugs elsewhere.
So the question was how
do we get to that
obscene type of scaling?
Does it ramp up?
Is it like a flood gate type
of thing, like I/O
registration?
A couple ways for me
to answer that.
One is that the App Engine
service actively
monitors your app.
So as your traffic grows, it
will actually create more
resources to be able to support
the traffic that
you're getting.
So one of the things is the
amount of traffic that you're
getting and the growth
at that's happening.
Another thing that's important
related to scaling is one of
the best practices--
it's actually part of my best
practice talk on App Engine--
which is try to have your app
respond in under 1,000
milliseconds, under 1 second.
The faster your app responds,
the more willing the App
Engine system is to
automatically scale your app
and just stretch you
out horizontally
as much as you need.
The slower you are, the more
that you'll be penalized.
So if you have apps that if
you're naughty and you're
taking several seconds or 30
seconds or something really
bad, you get put
in the corner.
You're getting demerits.
So those are ways to
get it to scale.
Another thing is if you're
working on a really large app
where it really matters, and
if you have a developer
advocate that you're working
with that's on the Cloud team
already, they can help you with
developing strategies for
load balancing and also
load testing, and
things like that, too.
And if it's really a big,
public event, it may be
possible to have your advocate
talk to the team about maybe
there's something that's really,
really big that we can
maybe help out with
on our side.
But as far as taking care of the
system goes, the engineers
responsible for making sure
that the system is up will
never look at one
particular app.
Even when the royal wedding
happened, they would not
monitor one app.
They monitored the system
as a whole.
It was those of us who are
public-facing that were
freaking out, staying up late
night, monitoring the app.
They were not monitoring
the app.
I was, OK?
So we don't do monitoring at
that level, but ramping up
slowly works fine.
Ramping up quickly works
fine as long as your
app responds quickly.
There's a couple of things that
you can do to help your
app respond more quickly to more
traffic as it comes in,
so you can look up warmups.
You can actually prepare an App
Engine instance before it
gets any traffic.
It can run some code to prepare
itself, like loading
some JAR files or whatnot, and
get it so that by the time
traffic hits it, users will
not notice the difference
between hitting that new
instance of your app versus
one that's already been
up and running.
So those are just
some answers.
There's probably others
that I don't know.
I haven't been on the team for
quite a while now, but I tried
my best to answer it.
Any others?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
How do you deploy the app?
WESLEY CHUN: How you
deploy the app?
That's a great question.
There's two different ways
of doing it right now.
You can do it from the command
line, where you just give the
appropriate command to upload
your app, and then you have to
give your credentials and
things like that.
It'll upload your app.
It'll tell you like
have we finished
uploading your app yet?
And also, once it uploads your
app, it also has to make sure
that your app is serving before
you get control back.
So typically, I would say
normally your app should be up
and going and about half
a minute or less.
It shouldn't take too long.
Maybe up to a minute
depending if the
system is busy or whatnot.
The other way of uploading your
app if via the UI tool
week that comes with the SDK.
So if you're on a Mac or a PC,
it comes with a tool called
the Launcher.
You just click on the Deploy
button, type in your
credentials, and it'll upload
your app there.
So those are two different
ways of doing it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHUN: Ah, yes, right.
We also added a get push
to deploy as well, too.
So that's the third one.
Sorry I didn't mention
that one, but yes.
Which may be the more modern way
of doing things, actually.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How does the CPU time
compare between using
Jython versus Python?
WESLEY CHUN: How does the CPU
time compare between using
Jython versus Python?
That's a good question, and
that is something that I
haven't measured before.
At the very bottom level,
it's all C code that's
running, even Java.
So everything runs at an even
level, so it's not like some
people think, oh, yeah, if it's
compiled code, if may run
faster than if it's
not compiled code.
But everything is bytecode
compiled already, so if you've
got a Java app, whether it's a
Jython app or a traditional
Java app, the Java bytecode is
compiled before your app runs.
Same thing goes, actually,
when you
upload your Python app.
All that stuff is compiled to
Python bytecode as well, too.
But I haven't done any
benchmarks to see.
But that's something that's
worth trying, thought.
And if you do that, contact me
and let me know what your
results are.
Thanks.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How much memory will
you have [INAUDIBLE]?
WESLEY CHUN: How much
memory do you have?
That's also something
else that's
not within your control.
If your apps starts using too
much memory, you'll be getting
some exceptions telling
you that.
There's no real ballpark number
I can really say,
actually, because it's just
something that really
shouldn't be something you
need to worry about.
I don't know if we have any
memory management tools to
help you with that, but yeah,
that's just one of those
things that's taken
care of for you.
I know that's not a great
answer, but if you have
something more specific that
you're asking about, like
maybe certain libraries you want
to know how much memory
you have, you can check
with me on that.
The other thing that's not
predictable, that is a
question that you did not ask
that is related, is how much
Memcache do you get with
the Memcache service?
That's also is not predictable,
too, because it's
a shared service.
It all depends on your usage
and other people's usage.
But also we're working on
a more dedicated type of
Memcache that you can kind of
control on your own, so that's
something that we're
working on.
Anything else?
All right, great.
Oh, one more.
AUDIENCE: Are the slides
published?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, I'll get the
slides over to Van or Kevin,
and you, Tom, or Peter,
and I will get them
available for you guys.
All right, thanks for
coming, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: Hang around
for piano stuff.
AUDIENCE: How long
is the show?
WESLEY CHUN: Oh, I'm just
playing one song.
[MUSIC PLAYING]